[Applause]
so let's get to the news and we're going
to start today with a story
about a motivational mom pranav sapra
and his mother poonam
have a viral instagram account where
pranav
shares his mom's pearls of wisdom with
the world and here's a window
into some of those insights some days
you have to paint your own your own
rainbows
and silver linings
even marathons are run one step at a
time
i like this one very much normalized
parents
acting like kids sometimes
so pranav thank you for sharing your mom
with us and let's follow her in every
way that we can
and tonight is the full harvest moon
and that's got to mean something
astrologically significant
and i would love to find out about it in
our wonderful astrology report
here to help us is ex astrologer
extraordinaire and
friend of this show eliza kelly hi elisa
hi
[Music]
i'm so happy to be back i love hanging
out with you
and you know i grew up in um when i was
like
in the 90s in particular in the 80s and
90s astrology was so
ubiquitous it was everywhere and it sort
of feels like
it kind of went like it dipped down a
little bit
in like the late 90s and the odds and
the 2010s whatever those are called
and i am telling you there is no sort of
hotter subject right now
and the interest and the connection to
it
is so alive and well and so i love when
you're here because i think there's
i think people are looking for
connection right now
and meaning so will you share with us
what's going on
this month well yes i am happy to share
what's going on
with this month because there is so much
going on this month
so i think that one of the important
things to remember with astrology is
that it affects everybody differently
and everybody is going to have sort of a
different experience with these planets
but something that everyone is going to
know is mercury retrograde
so mercury retrograde starts october
13th
so we should all expect for things to be
a little bit
more slow we're going to have to sort of
reel it in a little bit because it's
going to be a little
we're going to have more
miscommunications it's going to be a
little messy
but that's okay because that's just part
of the organic process
of the sky can i recommend a favorite
app of mine
it's called and it's just as simple and
straightforward i've never heard an
app titled this way is mercury in
retrograde.com
it's i guess it's an app and a website
but when you go on it it will say
yes or no and that's it and
uh i really love it i highly recommend
it all right let's get into all this
moon business tonight is the full
harvest moon
and uh what does that mean for us
earthlings so
during a full moon we have maximum
exposure from the moon
right we have full visibility so we can
see everything clearly the good the bad
the ugly
but what's really really interesting
about october is that we actually have
two full moons this month usually we
just have one but we have another full
moon
on october 31st which is halloween
so it's extra spooky it
first of all i know second of all
does it is it a blue moon when there are
two moons in a month yes because
everybody says once in a blue moon which
sounds like very very occasionally
but it the meaning of a blue moon is two
in one month you are you're filming
you're an astrologer you are an
astrologer already i'm telling you i
spent the entire 90s with like my nose
and every
astrology book and numerology and i
think there's so much celestial
scientific spiritual truth and if you
love astrology you love astronomy and
it's
there's math i mean there's so much to
all of this and
um thank you elisa so much thank you
drewing and thrilling news that you've
given us today we love you so much we
love you i love you
happy full moon and happy october
[Music]
you